you look like you can fight you what I'm
saying if I saw I'm like going I was
like a buck 20 back then and I didn't
know how to fight but n of those big
clothes I'll tell you what dude you're a
[__] piece I'll tell you that God
damn he look you look strapped up like
if you lift it up their shirt there's
like four
[Music]
pist welcome back to another essential
episode of careful boys today we got
Jesus with
us Jes we got the Jesus back uh just a
moment ago Jesus had a really good
question and I was like all right don't
say anything cuz we should just record
it cuz I I want to know the answer I
said why do Asians hate black people and
then you wait wait which one no not that
one that's because every time they leave
the store something's missing Ah that's
what it was Sor sorry about that that's
not what it was I'm pretty sure it was
you would have brought it up you had a
list
but no kidding it's a joke it's a joke
it's a joke his question was how come
all you Ching chongs always stick
together yeah dude but you know what the
funny thing he's trying to keep the
Japanese part out yeah that's what it
was huh that's what I thought about
that's what I thought about Mexicans
wait let him ask the real question the
real question is I've noticed that
Asians just hang out with Asians why are
you guys always hang out with each other
and just not like let other groups you
talking about kids or adults or in
general when I was in high school I
remember having like the Asian friends
and I was like that they're cool but
then they'll go do fun [__] and I was
never invited to it and I was be like
hey dude I'm down to like they're like
oh yeah for sure never invited me hey
were they all Kore were they all Koreans
they some of them are Koreans but but
the whole group I don't know most of
them were Koreans I don't know I can't
really I want be racist I can't tell you
but within Asians within Asians
especially in Southern California
Koreans just stick together okay yeah
okay like they won't Koreans wouldn't
invite me up no well I mean you are
confusing cuz what are you yeah Indian
uhhuh that's why I'll take right now
dude you're making me nervous sitting
next to you no but um I can see how they
just yeah is it why why is it though
what is it what's going on that's what I
thought about Mexicans though yeah and I
was like man all of you guys there's so
many Mexicans that it's hard to find new
friends I think cuz you have nothing but
Mexicans in your neighborhood that's
true cuz we like to I guess we like to
like listen to Mexican music we just
like to absorb our culture and you know
people that can relate to us are
Mexicans you know what I mean so like
think other nties are not having fun cuz
they're like I don't I do remember as a
kid uh when I was like in elementary
school there wasn't a lot of Asians
compared to white boys and Mexicans and
stuff like that so I always felt like
odd one out trying to hang out with
other clicks so you would only I would
only have the perspective that like
white people hung out with white people
or Mexican people hung out with Mexicans
so if I found another agent that
transferred into our school you just as
your go-to I'm going to [__] hang out
with that person I'm going to see if
they're going to hang out with me every
day you know what I mean cuz I was
always an accessory to some other click
that would like let me hang out
temporarily but not accept me into that
group oh God you know what I'm saying so
maybe and then when I eventually ended
up going to a school that had like hella
Asians you like then I found my place
yeah it it just felt right M I'm similar
too like in the beginning it was mostly
black and Mexicans cuz there weren't
that many Asians in the neighborhood I
grew up with then I moved here and
there's nothing but Asians there's
nothing but Asian and Mexicans actually
in the sgv so then that was most of my
friends San Gabriel Valley oh so most of
my friends were Asians and Mexicans cuz
it's like you got to go out of your way
to make white friends like you got to
drive all the way to the beach to become
friends with Chad right or like you got
to go to Inland Empire to be with sker
right right right the meth version but I
feel like yeah I feel like at all of us
I feel like you have the most white
friends maybe you got white energy I got
all kinds man white energy Japanese
imperialism and colonization he just
he's very like he thinks outside the box
he's he's not your normal Asian you know
what I mean he's got like s fun this guy
uh you know does Motocross right right
right right so like you would think
you'll catch him like meditating or
something in the roof but he's like
playing the guitar just like singing a
[__] song or some [__] he's one of
those guys he's just different different
guy right a lot of hobbies I think
there's it's pretty true what you're
saying though cuz I now that I think
about it I remembered that like when I
was in high school we did just hang out
mostly Asians but it was also because we
were so focused on being the coolest
Asians that I don't think I stopped to
like think like diversify my friends I
was just trying to compete with other
Asian guys all the time got you that's
so interesting I did notice that my
Asian friends I like their hang better
cuz it was never like uh it wasn't too
crazy and it was always like fun you
guys CU were like such a click that and
just like a the friendship was different
that I just felt like it was a little
bit more fun there was no like talking
[__] to each other there was but not
like to make you feel bad like Mexicans
we we'll go deep if a group is hanging
out one of us is going home cuz they're
pissed you know I mean that's a Mexican
hang you think Asian groups like Asian
groups they don't really roast huh they
don't roast as much they're very helpful
and you guys are more like uh out to do
cool [__] like I remember like you guys
were about the cars and all I did was
talk about cars and just uh drive around
we didn't even go party we just went and
drove their cars cuz they had the cool
cars dude I showed up I showed up in the
car meet with the [__] truck and they
were just like nah bro that's not what
we're doing they just had their little
Nissan gz's and those then they had
their [__] integras and just fcking
they Honda Civ do you do you see a
difference when you kickz I don't know
what the [__] they're when you kick it
with different like Asian groups do you
see a difference of like the cultures
yeah like so when you chill with like a
group of Filipinos versus like a group
of Koreans or something uh yeah Koreans
are to me this is my uh are the most
like wild like them boys are wild boys
wild Bo yeah they're wild boys like uh
when I party with this is a a friend
that's Korean that's of San Diego he's a
wild guy this guy is [__] we're going
to have a wild night like it's not going
to be a normal night and he's very
like he does a lot of cigarettes too God
damn [__]
God I'm like yo guy he's [__]
cigarettes knows everybody blah blah
blah karaoke bar at 5: in the morning
I'm like what the [__] are we doing dude
and uh uh I remember my I one thing I
did Noti like my Japanese friends like
they just like to like be at one spot
and stay at one spot they didn't like to
like move around they just like if they
were at a party we're at a party and
we're doing all the fun [__] at this
party you know what I'm saying they're
not going to go and go somewhere else
and they're just like nah we're going to
kick it here and at their house was like
the party and they never like to invite
anybody they didn't know it was very
weird I was like hey can I bite they no
no we're good where we're at and I'm
like just seven of us we're having a
great
time and I'm like well we could have a
bigger party but why and I'm like I
don't know why it's the Latin in me I
kind of l l you just want to invite the
whole [__] neighborhood and they like
hey we don't know what the [__] you're
thinking and bringing I'm like you're
right I don't know what is she thinking
or what he's bringing like Jesus Christ
so I did notice things like that um my
friend from Thailand we just love to eat
we ate everything we go and eat all
kinds of food so I don't know if that
those are my friends that I hung out
with I don't know if it's like that or
do you guys see a difference do
Vietnamese people do certain things
differently yeah I mean I I definitely
think that Asians can see the
differences in Asians very clearly for
sure but also Vietnamese people you guys
are angry you guys like to fight is it
just me or or am I tripping who are
crazy you're not tripping dud but the
women are they're kind of crazy they're
they like toight they're like
they like yeah they are they're very
like Snappy and to they're going nuts
right now just hearing you say this oh
no [__] dude I had a [__] Vietnamese
girl who just she never liked me you
know what I mean I would just show up to
the partner she be like go and they'll
talk their language and then how she
wants you to leave and I'm like why what
the and she just hated me she I got
under her skin I don't know why I was
just like what the [__] did I do to you
[__] God damn how many times that
happen every time we we I we were seeing
each other she just like a I'm like what
the [__] did I do maybe she wanted to
[__] you yeah I think her language I
think it was the [__] she like leave but
why'd you
leave yeah yeah yeah hey tell him to
come over and then we'll tell him to
leave Advanced flirting dog yeah that's
really that's I I had I've had the group
like do the whole like oh we're leaving
but they're going to go to another hang
spot but everybody's saying that they're
leaving and I'm like okay cool and then
I'll run into them at
a at the f SP that they're hanging out
at the parking lot like they guys are
leaving oh it's halfway through we
decided to come here okay cool I'm going
hang and everybody's like [__] and I
just like I never caught it onto it and
I like oh I think they want me to be
here I was like oh I actually got to go
yeah you should I'm like I should all
right then I'm out of here but yeah I
couldn't really hang too much cuz I
never had a cool car you know you guys
always had cool cars I think that's like
light in the bottom that's a big part
too is that I think growing up back then
we when you looked at Asian Hangouts as
like a subculture so if I hung out with
all white guys I couldn't really
identify with like them having
motorcross bikes and [__] I just didn't
know that world oh they like snowboard
they did like active like X Games type
[__] and I didn't own any of those
things and I in my mind I'm like I
couldn't even imagine having that stuff
yeah even partying with white guys was
was different like I would get like that
white boy wasted [__] was real like yeah
uh hang out with a white guy is we're
showing up to the party we're getting
[__] up right away right away we're
taking all kinds of [__] and in an hour
we're going to see where it took us
we're going to what is this d d it's
like a m yeah [__] yeah dude drink drink
drink this this and that and an hour
we're going to figure out what kind of
mood I'm going to be in and then they'll
going to this weird ass trip and I was
like wa but like Mexicans we like to
take our time like my my uncle they
drink so much I'm like hockey K drink so
much but then my white friends drink
like [__] couple white Claws and
they're like throwing up because they're
drinking us too fast Mexicans they take
their time I try to get [__] up my
uncles like that I'm
like
they look we have all night all night
God damn all night to drink day take it
easy I remember all my friends not being
like a I think that was more of the
result of the interests I was in yeah
yeah yeah so I remember like on in my
street it was pretty diverse and then
like in our Squad it was like me uh we
had an Indian homie a half white half
Chinese homie and the Mexican guy that
lived down the street and then a Korean
homie and then we were just like us five
so we're pretty diverse
and then I remember getting into like
swimming that was like pretty mixed too
and then I somehow I think yeah like in
junior highish you started to like try
to find her little group and then it was
either the skaters and I wasn't really
good at skating and then all the
Filipinos were really good at break
dancing it was like they just try the
windmill and they just get it the first
time they're like yeah [__] yeah I don't
I don't relate to that at all and then
I'm like oh These Guys these Asians they
smoke cigarettes my dad smoked
cigarettes I can smoke cigarettes I can
smoke cigarettes oh I think I I'm bored
to smoke
cigarettes cigarettes so you kind of
just I would love to see a picture of
him in high school yeah you kind of get
into that group and then I remember I
ended up moving out here and it was
crazy Asian but then I end up being on a
wrestling team and that was super
diverse so it was like its own little
pocket even though it's like half
Mexican half uh Asian but we have like
black guys white guys whatever and the
wrestling team and then everything was
more of a result of the interest rather
than like like oh let's cuz like right
now I'm super into fitness so in the
fitness realm it's like anyone everyone
guys girls different ages it's just all
the people that like to lift got you
yeah cuz when I was growing up for some
reason like Latinos like my interest at
that time was fighting everything was
[__] violent like fighting gangs all
this [__] was just it was like hot it
was like it was hot right now like we'll
go to the basketball courts and it would
be like dude on the way to the
basketball courts we're talking about
like oh if somebody trips I swear to God
ready Fu we were like praying a
[__] would we're like I wish
mother and then some guy's like dude I
wish somebody just
[__] we just wanted [__] to go down
bro and then like I had that energy from
like Middle School all the way to like
the middle of high school and Asian
friends other typ white friends and
stuff always said like dude why are you
so intense like cuz I would be at the
the drive like Hangouts and somebody
some guy would like come and like tell
us to leave and stuff like that and they
would just just be like quiet and I'll
be like [__] you what's up [__]
I would always they like dude you're
always going with violence it's like
chill dog and I'm over here trying to
get a rock and throw at them like hey
dog like and they will bring some sense
they're like dude if you throw a rock
and you hit them then they'll find us
and then we all get [__] in trouble
cuz maybe you can get away but what if I
get caught I was just in the circle I'm
going to get in trouble so why would you
do that you're my friend right I never
thought of it that way I ruins the good
time but back then that was the good
time the good time is everyone throws a
rock yeah you're not going to leave
empty hand we throw we we throw the
Rocks yeah no dude dude tell me that's
not him is that really him right there
dude get the [__] out of here dude you
look like you're why do you have that
you look like you're trying to solve a
math problem bro what the [__] are you
doing wait ho Yen Quan that's your name
no they [__] up on my birth
certificate so I don't know how but
that's how my name ended up being atele
only at keple to what no way this is
[__]
someone has your name then is this your
senior photo hey don't try and hide it
now dude just be proud of the fact that
you're [__] H dude it's
not look at his [__] red face right
now he's like no no D I swear to god
dude it's not my
[__] oh you're CH hang dude Chang dude
Chang's a tight name dude yo Chang how
did you find that [__] name dud Google
let's find [__] Joe now that we're in
it also Joe's just going to have
passfire in his mouth bro that haircut
is wild I always love how like if you
wore glasses for your photo you had to
like look like
this yeah cuz of the glare the glare
yeah they make you go dude I feel like
he's listening to ball with the ball the
[Laughter]
backa push me and then just touch me
he's just like you know I do remember
there was this one time where um in
elementary school I had this uh this
white homie who Liv lived in the
neighborhood and I was like Mom can I
bring my friend over right and he came
over and he didn't take his shoes off
and then she got mad at me later for it
oh yeah yeah yeah she goes you got to
teach these boys and she's like don't
you have any like Asian friends yeah
that did the respect is real that's
that's a real the respect is real if you
disrespect and then also like she
doesn't at that time too our parents
like they weren't trying to like learn
English super super well so like it
would be easier to relate to other kids'
families that had the same cultural
background versus like somebody who was
different so I think my parents always
like indirectly but like very directly
nudge me to try and have like similar
culture friends it's easier for them to
talk to your friends parents too yeah
yeah yeah they kind of wanted in that
little dude I didn't want to invite any
of my friends over cuz they weren't
Asian and they I knew they were going to
piss off my mom about some [__] like one
time my friend like had something in his
hands and he shook my mom's hand with
the his left hand and I'm sure it's not
an Asian thing but she just was like who
the [__] is is your friend like why the
[__] is he going to come in here shaking
my hand with his left hand who the [__]
does he think he is and just go off I'll
be like yo does that mean something or
is it just inconvenient it's just
because it's like lack of manners it's
that the sincere hand yeah like she
would trip on one time one of my
sister's friends came over first time
her coming over and she was like eating
some food and she's like she's going to
come to the house and just be eating
food eating our food not even her like
just she she was she came to the house
and she had some chicken from home and
she was eating it when she said hi to my
mom and my mom was like who the [__]
that's who the [__] what the [__] how
rude is this and we're like what the
[__] is this dude so we wouldn't buy any
of our friends over but if they were
Asian there would be more likely that
she would like them wow dude holy [__]
dude you're a [__] culture vulture
dude why you being a troller culture
vulture culture vulture [__] culture
vulture dude who's this lady you're with
I don't know oh my God bro what what did
you I didn't even know you can pull I
don't even remember honestly what game
fight that what game were you win bro
you're the these are the chinos I was
afraid of
dude are theary exct guy I was afraid of
Joe you're wild dude [__] yeah dude
that's such a sick ass photo we should
get a shirt like that and this is what
happens when you grow up in [__]
little Mexican neighborhoods right here
they [__] just like took on this
culture like I don't even remember where
we took that do you know who that is at
all you don't know what year this was
even I don't even dude she's a [__]
piece guy you for you she's a pce she
look like he dressed you bro she told
you like if you can hang out with me if
you're going to [__] this agent [__]
you got to have a little Mexican danger
in you and you're like all right she got
you the biggest size jacket Jesus dude
you you're a gang banger dude what rep
were you from [__] I don't know I think
I spent those two years on drugs every
day so I don't remember a lot oh my God
you're scary dude you're a scary guy
that's yeah you're a wild boy dude I
knew Jo was scary though I think I was
only like 17 or something in that you
look like you're 30 was like 17 or 16
you look like you're 30 hanging out with
your Sona homie yeah bro I never look
that old ever in my life yeah you look
scary as [__] you look like you can
fight that's what I'm saying if I saw
I'm like oh going to [__] me up going to
[__] me up I was like a buck 20 back
then and I didn't know how to fight but
not in those big ass clothes you I'll
tell you what dude you're a [__]
piece I'll tell you that God damn he
look you look strapped up yeah you like
you're going to stab me in the neck like
if you lift up their shirt there's like
four pistols
you're making the face that I would make
going to the basketball courts I wish
somebody
would I wish somebody would that's dope
dude that's actually pretty cool you got
yourself some [__] I don't know what
yeah but that was a different life for
me I want that on a shirt bro so that
look like such a [__] compared to you
in high school dude my [__] high
school picture look like a [__] I
don't have any pictures like that where
I look that cool P up your high school
picture dude uh it was so funny like uh
going back to what you said uh it
triggered me like my dad was so lowkey
my dad was racist to like my friends
like if I had my black friend over he
would be racist cuz but the thing is
he's trying to relate but it comes off
[__] racist bro oh yeah my dad my
white friend my black would come over
and I'm like oh I'm going to go grab my
my shoes real quick we're going to go B
all right for sure and my dad's like
sees him and he's just like hold on hey
and he'll change you to
basketball hey you like it B Michael
Jordan I was like oh that's Kobe I think
like Okay Go
Okay like that just knew one basketball
player Michael I'm like dude that's
that's cool right but then my friend
would just be like oh sick all right
cool and my white friends will come over
we're eating like soran hot dogs and
like that's all these fixes and then
like ooh is it like the bacon wrap yes
and my white with the bell peppers right
oh all that dude my white friend would
get all excited like oh I'm going to try
that my dad bring him a naked dog I know
you like nothing
nothing boiled it for you I know you
like nothing don't don't cook the weenie
okay I don't know they don't care their
tongues don't work don't I know you're
like nothing white people have broken
tongues
know no I know you like nothing I know
you like nothing just kidding news
careful boys is a brand just kidding
news is the man of smart people the
people of just kidding news careful boys
they are very smart just kiding news the
number one podcast in the
[Music]
world